Hey there!
Welcome to Life Noggin.
Do you really need to have any friends?
Besides me, of course.
Would it be better to have no friends at all?
I sure hope not.
I doubt my animator would make me anymore if he thought we weren't buddies.
But for the sake of science and risking my very existence,...
...let's find out.
Due to the research of some awesome Australian scientists,...
...it looks like having friends helps keep you alive longer.
They found that with older Australians, a strong network of friends...
...increased their chances of survival and living longer lives,...
...even more so than with connections to children and other family.
This could be due to friends having more influence in your decisions and choices.
Blood may be thicker than water,...
...but it looks like we still need that wonderful friendship H2O...
...so we can ride the great waterslide of life or something.
It also seems that having more friends...
...reduces your chances of making risky decisions in life.
Looking at a recent study, researchers found that people tend to seek out...
...money as a way to secure what they want out of the social system.
They found that feeling lonely or socially rejected...
...caused people to be more likely to choose riskier decisions in a gambling experiment.
Now, that might work out fine if you get lucky and the risk pays off,...
...but it's probably better to not base financial decisions off your emotions...
...and rather use that sweet noggin of yours.